let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
welcome welcome welcome
happy
happy
hump day
we are here
live
let's talk the tony michaels podcast
four o'clock eastern three o'clock
central every wednesday every
single one of them
and today today we have the [ __ ] list
for you but it got totally destroyed
because there's all kinds of breaking
news happening today
um you've seen on the [ __ ] list roundup
we had um eric trump come in the news
but also the verdict for the ahmad aubry
trial has has hit um and so we're we
want to talk about that today so i'm
going to bring gaben early on the [ __ ]
list here but first off i want to thank
you for joining us on the day before
thanksgiving
thank you thank you thank you and happy
thanksgiving to all you folks out there
all the audience everyone who likes
shares
and does all the good tweety tweets and
the trendy trends with us i really want
to tell you happy thanksgiving and i
appreciate you staying with us uh so
make sure to subscribe to the youtube
channel follow us on twitter and by the
way you know we have a special uh
twitter account for the tony michaels
podcast it's at
tony michael's pod go follow that
because at the end of the show today
we're going to tell you about the
bonehead of the week so don't forget to
go over there and vote for the bonehead
of the week uh
and also also also follow me on twitch
that's very very important for the [ __ ]
list roundup
every single weekday
again we won't be doing it tomorrow or
friday but we do it every single weekday
at noon eastern 11 central to go through
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
and that sort of thing
like we did today when um when some of
this stuff was hitting with eric trump
and we're gonna talk about some of this
on the [ __ ] list
and we also we also today we have a
great great great guest with us to do an
interview uh austin archer is our guest
he's a content creator sauce uh
singer songwriter he makes the tick tock
videos
and he's gone viral several times so go
follow uh austin at your pal underscore
austin austin archer on youtube twitter
twitch tick tock all the great socials
instagrammies go follow austin over
there we have a great new we also play
thanksgiving trivia
and uh i think i taught gabe and austin
in the actual trivia
a thing or two
about turkey day
um and you'll have to stick around to
see that that's that's at the end of the
show the interview and the trivia we
play thanksgiving trivia so stick around
for that we also have a special
appearance today by a great character
that i love
uh jojo from jurors does a character
called becky shoe some people think this
[ __ ] character is real
but we are gonna have her on a special
rnn clip today
so stay tuned for that
that's uh it's very it's it's hilarious
you guys are gonna love
uh the new uh rnn character and becky
sue with the rnn character that we came
up with the everyone loved the the rnn
from last week also go follow that
account there's supposedly a twitter
account out there of really news now
that's what it's called rnn really news
now it's really news i promise it's
really [ __ ] news
and it's not it's not it's not real news
it's right it's it's just there to make
you laugh make you laugh
because we got a lot of [ __ ] shitty news
and we're gonna get to the shitty news
right after this break we will bring you
the [ __ ] list right after this stay with
us
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
i've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babble mag
edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon i was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that i'm struggling with i
chose babble mag edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now i can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast
boy do we have a [ __ ] list for you today
um we had some uh some topics
planned for the [ __ ] list but there was
some news that hit that i definitely do
not want to ignore here on the tony
michaels podcast
we know
that the the
ahmad aubry trial and the verdict it so
here was our original [ __ ] list
rittenhouse waukesha subpoena city um so
i want to bring uh gabe in here real
quick and and uh we will uh
hey gabe how are you
hey what's going on
so um i wanted to bring you in on the
[ __ ] list today because because of all
the news hitting and uh it kind of
destroyed some of our shitless some of
it has to do with it as you see here um
we had written house uh we had waukesha
which i think there's some news on that
even because something's trending on
twitter about that and then subpoena
city of course with the january 6 select
committee stuff um going on i wanted i
wanted to make sure that we talked about
that so i wanted to bring you on and get
your thoughts not only about the
rittenhouse thing because there's a lot
of written house news out there right
now and then the waukesha but also this
uh ahmad aubrey as as the verdict
dropped this afternoon how important
that was did you watch the clip of them
reading the verdict
yeah i did uh i you know i i think i i
think everyone else also felt the uh
the person who was sitting in the back
of the courtroom who yelled out wu
during that you know in in like in kind
of relief and just like the the amount
of stress at this case and
and just the the amount of turmoil that
it's caused um
i think a lot of us were feeling the
same way
um you know unfortunately they were
removed from the court obviously because
you have to you know uh
while the verdict is being read aloud
you have to you know keep silent but i
think everyone else
um felt the same way that
that that person did you know um
there was just a i feel like a weight
off the shoulders you know for because i
think a lot of people also were feeling
that
you know it was kind of up in the air
you know uh and not to say that it
wasn't like as
like a closed case but there was some
anxiety that people had of like will
justice actually be served today or is
this another case where
like like the written house thing where
the country fails exactly right it fell
flat on its face now i i uh i actually
watched part of that where the there was
the disruption i don't know who that was
i didn't figure out who that was uh i
don't i don't know if it was part of the
family or not um it was hard to kind of
tell from the video
of who it was but like you said you know
obviously there's high emotion now the
judge did what he did is keep order in
his courtroom which is what should
happen um that's unfortunately what
happened with the written house trial is
the judge couldn't he didn't
i mean he was trying to throw the
courtroom into rittenhouse's lap and
unfortunately it worked maybe in in my
view um right but but we have we have a
verdict where
um the the son the one who actually
fired the weapon and killed
that that killed ahmad aubry um he was
char he was guilty of all charges which
includes malice murder which apparently
the malice murders life in prison so um
i hope that is exactly what the judge
can do is give him life in prison yeah
now the father um they dropped the
malice murder charge uh i guess because
he was driving the truck but he was
still i think there was four felony
murder charges and all the other charges
that were uh that were found and then
the other dude the guy who took the
video the guy who gave us all the
evidence that we needed to know that
they committed murder
um he was found guilty uh besides malice
murder a felony murder count they took
that one off and then they also took i
think aggravated us one of the
aggravated assaults off which i really
thought that was what was going to
happen here from the trial from all the
video is that they would charge the sun
throw the book at him rather he would
get all the charges or not i was you
know i was kind of up in the air but
then the dad would get less charges
because he was driving the truck he
didn't fire the weapon and then the guy
making the recording would get less
charges i figured that's the way it
would go yeah
um now
you know i i think
i think justice is served
in aubry's case and um i hope we can get
justice in some of these other cases
uh it's just sad to see now i actually
haven't went back to look at the
sentencing because we were working here
on the show to make sure we brought you
a good two hours of the tony michaels
podcast so we're a little busy to look
at the uh if there was sentencing but we
were talking about it before um because
you were saying something about you know
does he do it right there or does he not
because i i don't i don't really know
and maybe we're just talking at her
aspiring like hey right
the only one you know the ones that i've
seen uh that have been covered or
televised you know there it's typically
been all right the verdict has been
given and then the sentencing happens
sometime after you know they come back
in four or five weeks or whatever as the
judge is able to
look through
the verdict and assess what he feels is
the right you know going by the law but
then also
um his interpretation of what the the
punishment should be for the crime right
um so i i would
uh no i could be wrong but i would
assume that in this case um
uh even though they were all guilty he
probably is gonna take a minute to go
through and just kind of tally up
everything
um and make sure that you know it's the
uh the right punishment in terms of
sensing
right well and i i think that's probably
what will happen and hopefully you know
these these [ __ ] boneheads won't walk
free while he's deciding on the
sentencing i hope that's that's what
takes place yeah but in the meantime
we have rittenhouse meeting with trump
giving him the thumbs up with a picture
and his family which i actually called
this uh four days ago i actually tweeted
out when are we gonna get the picture of
kyle rittenhouse the thumbs up picture
with him and the cheeto dust mobster uh
you know not that i have some kind of
crystal [ __ ] ball but i knew i knew
donald trump the minute that he was
uh found not guilty and that little cry
baby fell on the floor well as soon as
he sent out that little press release
that he does yeah whenever he go
whenever he has a tantrum or whenever he
wants to celebrate something you know he
sends out to his email
list serve and says uh bt dubs uh i
think that also actually happened by the
way he said
uh congrats to written house who wasn't
guilty you know so on and so forth and
then at the end of it it was like make
sure to donate you know like well yeah
he's always trying so i think that's
actually the written house news don't
you is that the rin house news now now
that he's not guilty and all that
[ __ ] the written house news now
that's gonna continue is how are they
[ __ ] taking advantage of him because
they're going to which i i actually i i
think it's
i i think it's well fit for them to chew
him up and spit him out especially if
he's going to let him like tucker
carlson did uh i don't know did you see
cl i didn't watch the whole [ __ ]
interview but did you see clips of
[ __ ] little cry baby on tucker
carlson's show yeah i saw the clips that
obviously are you know putting him in a
position that's uh you know he's you
know pro blm and and pro uh rightfully
or
just uh protesting in a an organized
manner
um
and at the same time being like i had to
do what i had to do that [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] that guy uh
but yeah i agree i think at the end of
the day like every one of these people
it's hawthorne bobert gosar
mike flynn you've seen i think you
tweeted out the picture of him in some
kind of bar and grill
yeah the tiki bar which is in the same
town as
right he was meeting with mike flynn he
was meeting yeah yeah totally and and
i've said this hundreds of times he's
going to be out on stage i think i
actually said it in our interview with
austin is that we're we're going
we're going to see
these people trot him out in front of a
microphone kyle written house that is
and he's gonna say in one of these q
anon church evangelical maga rally these
these these trees and treason rallies is
he's gonna get out in front of a
microphone and he's gonna say i'm a blm
supporter and they're gonna cheer for
him yay you know the let's go brandon
crowd uh because that's gonna how
they're gonna shift the narrative of him
and how that's how they're gonna make
all kinds of money off of and he ain't
gonna see a dime the other clip from the
tucker carlson interview is when he's
talking about lynnwood and how linwood
raised like millions and millions of
dollars and like i didn't see a nickel
like no you didn't you're never going to
see a nickel this money because they
don't give a [ __ ] about you buddy
those guys were pimping them out from
the very beginning yeah
and john pierce
had they they bet they both had a dollar
sign on his forehead from absolutely
beginning
and you know here's the thing i will say
uh for you know attorney uh
his defense attorney richards
you know
i would say probably
the only smart voice in his corner right
right because he's the one that said hey
you need to change your name and just go
the [ __ ] away he was like don junior's
an idiot i agree with that
he said don't take any of these jobs
from these other morons right just it's
very toxic stay away and then to your
you know what you said is move away and
change your name right now
and you know something like oh i feel so
bad from it's like no [ __ ] the kid right
he brought it on [ __ ] consequences for
his actions and that's what it is and if
he tries to change his name or move
somewhere like unless he's moving to
europe which i very much doubt right
everyone is going to know what he looks
like like that face isn't changing he's
18. well i mean man this guy's a [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ] he's a young dumb [ __ ] he was
a young dumb [ __ ] when he did this [ __ ]
uh in kenosha and here's here here's
here's what they're they're dangling
carrots of fame and money in front of
this [ __ ] that's how tucker carlson got
the documentary that's how tucker
carlson got him on the [ __ ] show is
we're gonna make you famous and you'll
be rich and you'll be a hero he's not
this country doesn't like want that [ __ ]
we do not want kyle rittenhouse to be a
[ __ ] hero we don't want statues we
don't want libraries [ __ ] that guy that
guy's a murderous piece of [ __ ] we all
know why he went to that [ __ ] protest
he went to a black lives matter protest
because that young dumb idiot didn't
know
what why they were protesting and he
thought when he showed up at a black
lives matter protest that there were
going to be black people there and
that's why he took his ar-15 it's so
stupid that we have to even [ __ ]
constantly talk about why the [ __ ] he
went he's a dumb [ __ ] just like he's a
dumb [ __ ] that he's gonna go to these
rallies he's dumb [ __ ] that he went and
did the thumbs up thing with donald
trump he's a dumb [ __ ] he's a dumb [ __ ]
i'm just yeah we were joking about this
earlier but you know i am waiting uh for
the moment in which trump announces his
own internship
with uh with cal right now right and i
even saw there was someone online might
have been twitter might have been tic
tac i don't know but they made an
interesting point they said
uh
they said it's very interesting how all
of these um
republican lawmakers are making the
assumption that kyle rittenhouse is
republican right right like he's you
know he's now why is he why is he right
it's like what makes him what yeah what
is the attractive factor of kyle
rittenhouse that you think that he is a
republican uh a poster boy for your
party just what i said he goes to black
lives matter rallies with an ar-15 to
kill
liberals to kill black people that's
what they love about him right
but don't you think oh yeah it's like oh
we don't know his voting record we don't
know he's right he went on his family he
doesn't have the same time right doesn't
matter they made the assumption and it's
probably an accurate one considering the
fact that he was just meeting with all
these different people and specifically
trump giving that thumbs up at
mar-a-lago like the kid is it's 15
minutes of fame
uh you know i mean sooner or later he'll
probably just be like a kenosha pd
officer and oh jesus so so i want to
move on to the uh
uh
the christmas parade
um massacre and they're unfortunate yes
yes there is something turning on
twitter i want to bring that up here
it's uh hashtag uh wakasha
and that and then our waukesha waukesha
jesus yeah see wakanda wakasha i'm
getting it all confused
how do you say it
waukesha waukesha wisconsin people from
wisconsin are going to [ __ ] kill me
yeah waukesha massacre is trending on
twitter right
um and it seems like a bunch and we were
kind of looking at it before the break
but it was a bunch of right wingers and
what are they saying about the what what
what is what are they saying about this
thing because they have this guy in
custody obviously they they jumped the
gun on assuming it was this person it
was a correct assumption but that
doesn't mean they should have assumed
anything so here's the thing
and i brought this up to you the other
day uh is you know the daily beast did a
pretty good breakdown of the
the
strategy that you see from people like
tim poole and also andy know and how
what they'll do is they'll take very uh
early
information you know that maybe some
reporter has posted out there they'll
take that they'll post about it as if
they've been the one that discovered it
then they'll go and they'll scour the
social media pages facebook twitter
youtube instagram whatever find anything
that could be
uh
you know anything that looks bad in any
way then they'll take that and say look
at these four posts screenshots out of
context and say this person was anti
this they said this they
uh expressed violence toward this group
what have you you know and then at that
point now they're riling up the base and
they're feeding everything that needs to
be done then they move over and they
start saying like great tim pool starts
making a video where he gets hundreds of
thousands of views
and by the next day once things have
been corrected where it's like well we
don't know the motive right like we know
you know
there's mental illness
there's it was a knife fight like
there's all these different factors but
the first thing that they go to is this
is vengeance this is vengeance against
the written house verdict and it's like
no no this is a very shitty unfortunate
situation and it is not
the the byproduct of
of uh the written house verdict and so
then you've got people who are
complaining about oh he was out on bail
and da-da-da and this and that what i
mean which which which i that might be a
valid point but what the [ __ ] does that
have to do with written house right yeah
so there's all these things of like i
mean it's it's the classic whataboutism
so it's like oh here's this person
there's a problem okay great and then
they bring up all the small little
things they build it up but things like
you put a bunch of tiny [ __ ] together
it'll make a decent [ __ ] mound right
enough where people can smell it and be
like oh what the [ __ ] is that and they
can't they can't not
point it out and then what ends up
happening is you get these people like
annie know and tim poole and other
right-wing
yes and they'll make the videos and
tweets and write articles and this and
that but then boom just blast all the
internet before they have actual 100
verification that this is either the
person or this is either the motive and
what ends up happening is by the next
day or two when things get corrected uh
they're already on to the next victim
right they're already they moved on they
don't care they've already said what
they needed to to get the views to get
the engagement to get the people riled
up so that they can that they can
continue to stir that like that that
pool but that you're saying you're
saying this is all this is all pre
meditated by these these people
circulating lies and misinformation and
what you're saying is it's it's a
strategic plan and there's a thread and
i read it and it's pretty good that you
posted uh why don't we you should go
find it and uh put it at like the top of
your timeline or something that way we
might be able to tweet it out on the uh
the podcast account here in a bit
but i think i think that's um i think
that's a good point where they try to
you know they try to [ __ ] make this
[ __ ] you know they have this strategy to
get this misinformation out there and
and the old adage is that the lies will
spread all the way around the world
before the truth gets out of bed and
puts his [ __ ] shoes on so and i think
that's kind of their strategy is to to
create these narratives um and that way
that is the narrative no matter how
[ __ ]
how much you try it's that's going to be
the narrative that it is 100 i mean like
even if you look at anything that in the
last year or a year and a half if it's
taught you anything about how people
behave
especially within the internet right
you'll get someone who goes off on some
random conspiracy about covid or about
uh you know george floyd is a crisis
actor or whatever these non
not founded in any sort of truth or
proof or anything
but you get someone who
throws it up on whatsapp and then they
share it to facebook and then they're
posting to instagram and then it's on
twitter and by then like the cycle of
lies
have have come back around and the
problem is too is like once the truth
comes out right to say like
this was the motive or this was the
person or this was the event just you
know in complete contrast to uh what was
done
to or what was what was um claimed to be
done
it doesn't matter anymore
you know how like it's it's nearly
impossible to correct someone's
uh thinking if they're already under the
suspicion or belief that
the first one was right you know right
and well and
well
speaking of the truth and knowing what's
right and what's wrong that brings us to
the third topic which i was going to
talk about today but this this is uh
subpoena city we're talking about the
january select january 6 select
committee and the the the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup as i call it the
insurrection on january 6
but we see on twitter today eric trump
starts trending and the reason why eric
trump starts trending is because uh
something about burners but this comes
on the heels of uh roger stone getting
subpoenaed uh
uh
we have alex jones but before that we
have mark meadows who's likely to be
held in criminal contempt which comes up
on this burner phone right kind of story
too he's in that [ __ ] story um
i mean
we we have these lies that again will
get their asses up and work all the way
around social media before the truth has
time to put on its [ __ ] shoes and get
out of bed same same [ __ ] thing with
this eric trump um
i i mean i don't know if uh
if it's still trendy or not we can take
a look here let me uh let me add our
stream back in here uh but the eric
trump thing was the burner phones and i
i was very because uh i did it on the
[ __ ] list roundup today i wasn't sure
if they were saying eric trump had the
burner phone and was calling other
people burner ferns or people were
calling them on off burner phones right
so basically what i had read was that
there were three sources that said uh
kylie cremer took one of the phones and
used it to communicate with white house
and trump campaign officials who's
who's who's kylie kramer uh is a top
official in the march for trump group
that helped plan the uh
the uh
ellipse uh rally right decided to be an
aide and pick up the burner phones days
before the january 6 according to three
different sources
right
and it was described as having the
burner phones were of the utmost
importance and the thing is
that the people included were eric trump
his you know the president's second old
son uh also [ __ ] idiot uh his wife is
that beavis or is that butthead is that
beavis or i'm not really sure which one
uh is he beavis or butthead which one is
he i forget
but then you got lara trump who is the
steel two million or you know i guess
steel embezzle uh two million dollars
away from a dog charity right and uh
well i mean [ __ ] eric trump is the
children's just still all the children's
charity yeah i mean again you know birds
of a feather right
turds of a feather whatever you want is
that is that what you said on twitter
didn't you say something like that i
said i said birds of a feather but it
was it was regarding the people that
were offering kyle rittenhouse an
internship oh well same [ __ ] same
[ __ ] people it's like all of the
terrible people are offering this kid an
internship
i mean when do you think when do you
think we see uh these members of
congress uh be uh subpoenaed
oh i think
i think it's coming soon i hope i mean
peop definitely people like uh lauren
bobert right um you've got uh
uh marjory taylor green there's another
one
um
you know obviously paul gosar's on that
list and they're right i mean several
people that you know from the very
beginning who are they're like i wore a
bulletproof vest and it's like why were
you wearing a bulletproof vest for a
very peaceful that was that was mo
brooks wasn't it right yeah exactly so i
mean we have all these people that's why
i call it subpoena city and i like it
subpoena city because it's just like
like when you go into a big huge [ __ ]
discount store and it's just like people
you get and so the oprah thing you get a
subpoena you get a subpoena you can't
see no really and you have you ever
heard the uh uh it's a weirdo thing it's
a movie he did in the 80s and he does
this thing called spatula city where
they just sell spatulas oh yeah yeah
yeah you said bachelor city special
cities right subpoena city maybe we
should do a video for people yeah maybe
weird al would be pissed off i don't
know maybe he would like it maybe we'd
get him to [ __ ] retweet it or
something
uh but but you got that you got
someone's someone's delivering a
subpoena to gabe or is that a fire truck
it's a it's it's both oh okay well
someone in my neighborhood is getting
suspina right now right right now well
are you neighbors are you neighbors with
any of the insurrectionist
i
mean no okay well you know it happens
when you're doing when you're doing
shows like but back
back to the subpoenas
um
as far as as far as like alex jones and
roger stone
we seen those subpoenas come down um
do we do do you think because alex alex
jones did you see the clip of him like
in the middle of a [ __ ] yeah he's
totally saying something like oh i'm
gonna i'm gonna plead the fifth or some
[ __ ] or anything here's the thing he's
like i'm 47 years old i'm not gonna show
up to some uh uh you know kangaroo well
he didn't say kangaroo but basically he
was like some court where they already
got a target on my back and they they
want to prove me wrong and then they're
gonna prove then they're gonna trick me
up and say that i was lying so they hold
you know hold me in and here's the thing
it's like
innocent people who did nothing wrong
don't have to fear anything right and if
they were innocent then the truth will
you know in most context people contexts
well you remember you remember back in
2016 there was a guy named mike flynn i
don't know if you know this guy or not
but there's a guy named mike flynn he
was standing on the stage at the
republican national uh convention when
they were nominating grandpa poopypants
to be their nominee right and he stands
on stage and he's talking about the
email lady do you remember the email
lady boy the email lady let me tell you
something yeah the one yeah she was on
trial right now she actually she
actually went and testified for 11 hours
right yeah he said he said record right
exactly well he actually said on stage
that if you have nothing to hide
then why wouldn't why why wouldn't you
come in why wouldn't you so same
[ __ ] because they're always
projecting that is covering up messages
burner phones defrauding people for a
border wall
probably emailing classified information
on private servers more than likely also
there also was that um
last year there was the
revelation that or the reveal that
happened about uh
uh ivanka and jared and how they were
using personal phones and unsecured
messaging and emails to conduct business
so you know it was for a period of time
before they had to switch over but at
the same time it's like
all right yeah let's uh look at the
servers you know well
i i think there's gonna be a ton to look
at and i actually believe uh because i
keep hearing people say oh they're never
gonna see justice with this select
committee i believe we are tiptoeing
towards it and i think that's actually
that's reason why it's a trickle trickle
trickle thing um and i think that's the
thing so sorry for the shitless getting
uh totally torched today but thanks kate
for joining us with [ __ ] list just stay
right here gabe don't go cause we're
gonna be right back after these messages
stay with us
you sit your ass down sit the flip down
we're not finished
the tony michaels podcast we'll be right
back
headlines
[Music]
president joe biden releases 50 million
barrels of oil from the strategic
petroleum reserve to lower gas prices
for american families
thanks brandon
[Applause]
[Music]
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show
as you know i am the king of brilliance
the tony michaels welcome back to the
tony michaels podcast
thanks for putting up with the uh the
the patch together [ __ ] list there
we really do apologize uh for
for having for having uh
having to to
go on the fly there but we did it we
made it i i
i didn't i didn't want to ignore the
mod aubry trial i think it was very
important so i see you have on a uh a
hawaiian shirt today yeah yeah very
you know uh you know it's my party shirt
okay so like this is the
pre-thanksgiving party or or what yeah
well you know like uh it's loose i'm
sure by the end of thanksgiving it'll be
tight you know for all our listeners out
there that aren't watching this show
yeah
gabe's got on this nice i mean how would
you describe it it's a hawaiian shirt
but it's got this it's a once
got this
thanksgiving vibe to it maybe you know
yeah right
some sort of like west coast
thanksgiving west coast pumpkin pie is
that what we call the shirt west that
could be a song west coast pumpkin pie
couldn't that be a shock you know we
should we should uh maybe talk to uh
austin about making a song yes i am very
excited about the interview we play
thanksgiving trivia and spank speaking
of thanksgiving
there's that uh zero hour with bill
yeah yeah and then uh one i was watching
last night it actually uh there's they
brought a guest on her name's becky sue
apparently she's their national crt
correspondent or something
uh yeah and it was on uh i think his
name the host name is carl tuckerson i
don't know
yeah apparently carl tuckerson is the
host name i actually i think i have
sounds like a dick
he is he is uh complete
he is a complete dick but let me let me
see if i can
play it so we can uh show the audience
this this new network thing in this show
[Music]
hi i'm carl tuckerson and welcome back
to white privilege tonight with
thanksgiving upon us and our american
values in jeopardy we're going to hear
from our national crt correspondent
becky sue
some of you may recognize her from your
facebook ivermectin group becky sue
welcome to the show hey carl where are
you calling us from well i'm hiding in
my bathroom why are you whispering
because my boyfriend's parents are here
and they're the worst they're worse than
the worst they're lips they've been
going on and on about joe biden and
equality blah blah it's like freaking
wokes giving around here oh my god i can
only imagine oh it's bad it's real bad
first they were going on and on about
january 6th being a bad thing which is
crazy then they were talking about that
cutie pie kyle written house
and they hate him of course so i brought
up crt
seeing that's how it's ruining my future
step foster kids uh chrysler and dodge
crt is truly ruining our children them
kids is here but their daddy ain't he's
my boyfriend bobby he's down at the
police station fulfilling his community
service obligation i mean doing his very
important patriot work
washing the police cars so anyways i
said to his parents that the libs are
poisoning kids with crt and it ain't
right i'm pretty much an expert on the
subject i did a bunch of research one
day last week on facebook and uh that
shoney's has real good weekly so i
pretty much got the best info out there
too what did they say well first they
said that i didn't know what i was
talking about and they tried to trip me
up ask me what crt stood for like i
didn't even know of course you know what
it stands for
well duh
it's critical rice
training because they're training our
kids to hate their race they're training
them to hate racisms if it's not even
their birthright and stuff it's just sad
and then i said the patriot pilgrims
didn't act all embarrassed of their
whiteness when the native americans came
into their town looking for free corn
and stuff the pilgrims gave them lots of
food they gave them like fish
and
donuts
and
spaghetti
and the native americans were grateful
they didn't go make their little kids
learn cpr i mean crt in school so
bobby's parents got all quiet and their
jaws were like on the floor and they
didn't know what to say
so i won that fight
had a girl becky sue well i gotta go see
if bobby's back from doing his uh very
important police work and grab myself
another hard lemonade becky sue thanks
for coming on the show well thanks for
having me carl i'm such a big fan of
yours i love your bow tie
anyways happy thanksgiving
next up we find out which flavor of mayo
is best to put on your thanksgiving
turkey
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
what is going on over there
over at rnn they apparently have a show
called white privilege tonight with carl
tuckerson i've never heard that's
definitely on the news yeah well you
know that that carl tuckerson he seems
uh he seems familiar i'm not sure where
i uh
he i i couldn't tell you maybe it's uh
you know you draw your own conclusions
to where you've seen you man you know
right i guess just got one of those
faces
but uh becky sue uh
thinks that uh the pilgrims serve donuts
in spaghetti is that the yeah and uh
yeah fish donuts and spaghetti yeah yeah
well i think actually in our in our
thanksgiving trivia that we play with
austin here in a bit i think we we
actually go over some of the uh the
original the original thanksgiving right
yeah yeah yeah yeah
so stay tuned uh for the for the rest of
the show here in a little bit because we
get to the bottom of some of the the the
question are the answers to some of
these questions about the original
thanksgiving so speaking of thanksgiving
i do want to tell our audience again
happy thanksgiving but uh do you have
any special plans for thanksgiving or
are you going anywhere are you traveling
or
uh not traveling anywhere out of the
state i'm tr i'm uh i'm gonna be
spending thanksgiving with my girlfriend
and her sister and gotcha husband and
then uh my girlfriend's uh parents and
grandparents well happy thanksgiving
i hope you guys have a great meal i'm
spending uh thanksgiving with my parents
and we're finally gonna eat turkey again
together last year we didn't get to
because they were actually quarantined
for kovid and then we had the whole you
know pandemic i don't know if you heard
about the pandemic but what's that
the pandemic you remember the uh you
know again remember yeah yeah
but yeah
no
no no i don't i don't recall what's up
so so thanksgiving though
um
when i was a when i was a kid
every thanksgiving we would go
and it would be a big family get
together and of course you know the
american tradition
of of thanksgiving is that how it was
when you were a kid did you have the big
family get together when i would have
thanksgiving with my family that was in
wisconsin for sure you know right uh
you know you
it was a whole thing where you know i i
didn't hunt at all but there were
occasions when i would go you know wake
up at three in the morning drive out
yeah
you know no no noise can't do anything i
just had to sit there as a kid
and watch my uncle and cousin just hunt
and yeah do that for hours and then you
come back and you clean up meanwhile
people have already been cooking
sure
football games on and so what's your so
what's your favorite thanksgiving food
then what's your favorite one like the
one that and it doesn't have to be a
specific thing but like maybe someone
made a certain thing what's your what
was your favorite like you were looking
forward to uh
yeah there's a
uh my dad uh would make a stuffing yeah
um
and i could not tell you the i mean like
the basic ingredients of like you know
croutons and celery right right you know
and all all the good all the good
fixings but um
that was something because my dad's also
a chef so it was
you know he would also take basic
um or the standard
meals like potatoes and be like oh well
you know it's not gonna be quite mashed
potatoes we're gonna do rustic potato
you know mashed potatoes which is like
still got the skins and stuff like that
you know um so it would be like like
fancy dishes
they wouldn't be fancy it would just be
like it's just like just spruced up a
bit yeah yeah there'd be a little little
spice you know right the the yeah yeah
so yeah
i'm sure your dad did the whole uh yeah
i'm sure he's also like i would never
[ __ ] do that
so so but you but what was your fault
like what was your favorite thing the
thing that you looked was it the turkey
was it the ham was the it the stuffing
then i didn't have too much ham i will
tell you this growing up never really
had a lot of ham turkey was always he
would always do something different like
he might deep right he might smoke it he
so he would cook it differently yeah
yeah yeah because we would deep fry
he would get
a good rich flavor it wouldn't be super
dry it'd be right right because turkey's
turkey's a [ __ ] you know like
yeah like if you ever right so so
that's why a lot of people like to deep
fry or smoke them because you keep that
moisture because when you bake a turkey
it's just you know it's it's a mug
you've got to keep you got the the base
right you got to keep going right
because you got to keep that moisture in
there because you can't have no dry ass
turkey well i mean you can you just got
to pour the gravy all over it to eat it
i mean it's a it takes a long time to
cook a turkey you know oh well hours
depending what you're doing and what the
style is but yeah i mean it's a big-ass
bird it's a big-ass bird
it's so that's that's why uh um last
year because we didn't have a big
thanksgiving so we just cooked the the
turkey breast you know we just bought a
turkey breast yeah well i mean it was
just it was just us so i didn't eat a
whole [ __ ] 20 pound turkey you know
it won this big meal so we just brought
the breasts and that was a hell of a lot
easier to cook i'll have to tell you oh
because i used to what i would do is put
like tons of broth inside the turkey to
keep that damn thing moist yeah yeah the
other thing and i'm sure someone has
done this and i'm sure you could go onto
youtube and find a video of it but one
thing i've been curious about is like
seeing someone who's done a sous-vide
turkey
shoe what a sous-vide do you know what
sous vide is you're gonna have to
a sous-vide is a tool that allows you to
it's the process of cooking like um
basically preparing people will do it
with meats
fish what have you typically they're a
thinner but they'll put it in like a
ziploc bag and then they'll put it into
uh
a a uh
some summer like a container do you know
what this is do you know what this is
yeah i'm just trying because people do
different ways they put in a pan or like
a pot right and they'll have their tool
but basically it uh it keeps it slowly
cooks it
right in water
and then what you'll find is like uh
you'll be like great i cook this salmon
and then i'm just here to sear it you
know more like i cooked i cooked the
steak and i'm just here to sear it you
know i'm just
add a little
little flavor on there uh yeah do you
see that yeah do this yeah you know off
the off the forum right into the dish
but anyway so it would be a lot of water
and i would i'd be curious but i'm sure
it's possible basically what you're
doing is you're just heating water
to cook this thing evenly
and
it also you know it's better flavor you
can marinate it you can cook the
marinade right inside the bag you know
it's the whole thing well let's let's
let's let's let the audience do a little
bit of research do their own research
maybe on their facebook groups their
turkey facebook groups not the
horse-paced cyber mectin groups
definitely don't learn how to cook
horse-based over there but
let's let's take a quick break and when
we come back after this break
we'll play the interview and we'll play
some trivia so stay stay right here
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa don't delay and
get your part in blanket today for just
99.99
actual parting's not guaranteed
the tony michaels podcast wednesdays at
4 p.m eastern 3 p.m central watch live
on youtube on twitter and twitch
download on apple and spotify now here's
tony
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the show the tony
michaels podcast we are very excited to
have our guest here today
songwriter tick talker content creator
famous cam girl now austin
archer he's at your pal underscore
austin on the socials austin thank you
for being here
your pal austin is with us today thanks
for being here buddy oh i'm so excited
to be here i told you to plug my cameo
and you said cam oh
oh cameo i i was i was i
yeah absolutely i can either confirm or
deny whether or not i will do explicit
sexual acts on cameo for people if they
pay
but
i just wanted to clear that up oh okay
well you said i have fans
on cameo so i was like only fans cam
girl i was confused yeah i i really
apologize uh so let's scratch the cam
girl thing but you know if you're
willing and able go to cameo and check
austin out there he apparently
is taking requests he apparently so how
is that you know what let's let's play
because i i think this is your newest uh
video isn't it the cameo
let's play that so we break for this ad
let's let's show everyone let's show
everyone austin
on right now after a short commercial
being a k being a cam girl i just want
to let you know that i got us started on
cameo you did what it's this app where
people can pay to have you make like
videos yeah i know what it is why did
you do that well they said that it might
who are they the people at cameo and
what they say they said that
people might wanna
have me do cameos and you believed them
cameo is for like big celebrities you
know that right
yeah do you think you're a big celebrity
no
i can't believe you did this i've
literally never been more humiliated by
anything in my life well i can just
delete it i'll delete it no don't delete
it you've got it now you might as well
just like
try to make it work who knows there
might be
some people who might
want to do that for some reason i don't
know you probably have to make like a
promo video to let people know that
you're doing it to yeah that's what um
that's what this was
this was gonna be
that this is the promo video it was uh
it was gonna be yeah yeah this is not
this is not very good man this isn't a
good promo video
okay just just
like just look at the camera and be
excited and let them let them know about
uh the cameo okay um
hi i'm on cameo but also like tell them
that it's just like as a joke
just like as a joke though it's not a
big deal unless they actually want one
in which case uh
it's not a joke unless unless you want
it unless you uh unless you want that
unless you want to do one because then
you can and then it is for real if you
want it to be
yeah i think that that i think that i
think that works
hey looking for a fun and unique holiday
gift idea how about get someone a fun
cameo from me austin or don't it's
whatever it's not a big deal
fantastic fantastic the tony michaels
podcast is brought to you by
our new sponsor our new surprise so go
go go uh go use the use the promo code
tony uh at austin's cameo page and get
25 percent off your illicit photos of uh
uh uh excuse me the cam girl excuse me
uh um
that the the celebrity video of of of
your choice at arson austin archers
cameo that that's fantastic so so
obviously we have someone on the show
that is uh a huge tick tocker and i also
have a tick tock account that's kind of
where i came from i'm not near as big as
followers if i i don't have near the
followers that you two have gabe also
has a very popular tick tock account and
and we all probably have our own stories
about how tick-tock came about but
um what were you doing before
tick tock like what happened before that
happened i think like so many people who
are on the app and who are uh you know
kind of entering the creator economy
right now like i'm an actor i'm a
musician i'm a singer songwriter like i
was
uh like so many actors like we sit
around waiting for opportunities to be
told we can go to work you know like we
like a lot of what we do is we record
self tapes and we send them to casting
offices and especially now in the
pandemic area it's all self tapes and uh
uh
actors and and people who are
sitting around waiting to get a green
light to go do the thing that they do
like to find ways to
occupy themselves when they're not
working
which is a lot of the time and then when
the pandemic happened and like theaters
shut down
and a lot of tv shows and things shut
down production there was no work for
actors everybody jumped on tick tock and
tic toc kind of exploded and musicians
were all the sudden realizing like oh i
can like market my music on tick tock so
much more effectively than if i were to
hire a pr company to do i mean i i put
out an album in 2020 and i paid like 3
500 to
have like different blogs write up do
write ups about my album and like do
reviews and stuff right and honestly it
was like the worst money i've ever spent
on myself because the the exposure i can
get on tick tock for free is so much
better if i can just figure out a way to
like do it so it was just that it's like
you know my whole adult life i've been
putting out albums and writing music and
acting and and writing and stuff like
that and then tick tock was kind of
that platform that i think
like vine couldn't be tick-tock because
it's not long it's not it's it's this
very specific kind of humor right and
even when instagram tried to introduce
short videos it wasn't it didn't have
the like
the creator-centric vibe where like they
really
they really encourage you to do like
good editing and stuff and to make it
like a little mini movie right right tik
tok was like the perfect thing for
creative types who were looking for a
creative outlet because it really gave
them
simple user-friendly tools to make a
little video that can kind of showcase
their personality and their artistic
sensibility and
the kind of aesthetic that speaks to
them and like
i don't know i think that it was this
platform that a lot of people were
waiting for and then when it it sort of
started taking off and it became more
than just teenagers dancing and people
mouthing scenes from tv shows
you know
yeah
we all and also like the discoverability
factor on tick tock is something that
we've never seen before right where like
you can really
grow organically in ways that like you
just can't it's so much harder to do on
other platforms well i think i think
you're right because uh
tic tac to tony michael's your entire
statement there it's basically like
turn your camera on record and put that
[ __ ] [ __ ] on the internet right i
mean like that's like that and and do it
over and over and over and over and over
again at least six times a day right
like that's like that's the kind of the
soup that tick tock lives in and my
experience with it was that i was
frustrated and i just started yelling
into
the phone about politics and now here we
are and i know and i know everyone's
journey on that on that platform is a
little different um and and i know gabe
has his own story of tick-tock in that
flat platform but you're saying what
you're saying is so did you have
tick-tock before the pandemic or did the
pandemic lead you to like hey i'm
sitting in my house anyways i might as
well just start you know making this
making this content into the phone and
sharing it with people i had a tick tock
account before the pandemic and i had
posted like three videos and i had
34 followers that were just like people
from my contacts list that i added that
added me back
and i i was on there at the beginning of
the pandemic at home
see i was noticing that like tick tock
was sort of taken off and that a lot of
people were using it and there was this
trend at the time going around where
big creators or creators were like fifty
thousand sixty thousand followers would
be like here's how i got 50k in three
months and then i follow for the tips
you know and so i started like making
videos where i was making fun of the
trends that i was seeing on there so my
video was like here's how i got 34
followers in six months and i just was
like i added a bunch of people from my
contacts list they added me back
that's
it it's like i got 34 followers but that
was my first video that like went
viral i'd never had anything go viral
before and all of a sudden i just saw
this like avenue too like oh i can
i can really use this to market my music
and to market my podcast and to market
the different things that i into market
myself as an actor
and i think that
that was initially the direction i
wanted to go in was like doing skits and
doing songs and stuff like that
um
the politics stuff just sort of happened
accidentally it was like once i had a
big enough platform i kind of felt like
i couldn't not
talk about certain things it was like
all the black lives matter stuff was
happening right in 2020 with george
floyd
and brianna taylor
and it just and people were asking
people who were following me were like
will you say something about this and i
was like yeah you know i feel like
white creators have this
have the privilege and the opportunity
of like opting out of the conversation
they can just be like nah i'm just a
funny guy i just do funny stuff
and uh
and like other you know like people from
marginalized communities don't
necessarily have that option to be like
right nah
like right i'm gonna do funny stuff
right so so so what you're saying is
like sometimes uh certain creators are
thrust into this uh of their you know
just because of the color of their skin
or or you know
yeah they're like they're like i'm
trying to just make funny stuff and
racist people are showing up in my
comments and like right like making me
forcing me to like angry
right forcing you into the politics of
it yeah you know and i can't sip out my
my front and really it's like if you're
if you're uh
bipac in america or if you're queer in
america like your everyday existence
your life is like you're constantly
coming up with the
uh coming up against the fact that
people are politicizing your identity
and politicizing
if whether you're just trying to be
funny on the internet or not and so that
doesn't really happen to us that doesn't
really happen to like white guys so we
sort of have to like opt in we have to
be like hey people are paying attention
to what i'm saying maybe i should
say something about what i think is
correct in this instance this political
thing right right well and i get i get
that a lot because of how i sound and
how i look you know what you're saying
is
in other words i get people coming in
going where's all the where's all the
trump trolls where's all the internet
trolls and i'm like well they they come
on my video and they see me and i think
it confuses them because i'm like i'm
i'm saying the same the same language
that they would speak i'm just aiming it
in the opposite direction right yeah
yeah and so i never really got a lot of
the the trolls i mean i try to stoke the
trolls i i honestly like the trolls
everyone else is like i don't want the
truth i i'm like yeah get in there you
know really pump the algorithm i want to
spread this around and so all the trump
bumpers see that there's white dudes out
here with a beard on that looks like
them that wear hats that aren't [ __ ]
dumb you know like like that's what i
like i i want them to see my content
i know it pisses them off so much so
that they won't even comment that's how
i know that they they won't there's
nothing i there's nothing i love more
than a video from like uh
like a white
like southern dude or like like dude
with like a like like you got backwards
cap on with a beard who sounds like a
good old boy who's telling them all what
a bunch of dumb [ __ ] racists they are
i'm like i love this guy yes every time
i see a video with some guy who's like
hey listen i was at the cookout
yesterday and you y'all were [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm just like i love that [ __ ]
i'm like hell yeah
you should make you should make that
character on your videos
there's definitely been a few that i've
seen across six act where i do
you know the the preconceived notion i'm
like oh god another one of these you
know in the sense of like oh this is
going to be a bad take
and it's like some guy in a 18-wheeler
truck you know and he get you know it's
like that meanwhile it's like you had us
in the first half you know yeah and then
he does a 180 and you're like oh that
was okay that was actually pretty good
and you wouldn't expect it right and
right i think it breaks you you know i
think
one from our like from
a progressive side or what do you want
whatever you want to call it like
you might be like
radical socialist yeah that's right
radical social that's that's the label
well you come into the video and you're
like oh god and then they you know and
then you're kind of one over but then on
the other side the far right wing they
see they're like oh yeah just like me
and they're like really into it and
they're like wait wait wait no no no no
no and it's like it's too late there was
there was a tweet that i saw yesterday
that was really great that was it was uh
some guy tweeted like
you know i i'm
anti-vaccine i don't wear a mask i'm
anti-science i
uh i
um don't believe in free health care i
don't believe in
um
you know like uh
all this stuff that had to do with like
quality of life in america and then at
the end of it he said i'm pro-life and
it was it was like that it was like it
was a troll because it was like he's
listening up all these things and then
someone commented underneath a fox news
you know blonde woman from the fox news
news machine i don't know who she was
but she commented another thing she goes
honestly i thought she goes i was
reading this entire tweet going oh these
are all the things that i think and then
i realized at the end that you were
making fun of us and i was like that
that's it's exactly what you just said
like i'm surprised that she even
commented and i'm like yeah maybe you
because now you're gonna get ratio but
all right right yeah well you know you
know that that happened on the uh who
was it gabe that gene simmons came out
was it last week or he's like [ __ ] these
anti-faxers [ __ ] them it was uh
bridgette gabriel who who yes there you
go point out she has never found
uh a crisis
or
an outrage that she could not try to
exploit and i mean that's her that's her
whole game right well yesterday
yesterday she had a tweet where i was
like this is a bad take whether and i
tweeted about it and she said um
uh
basically uh
young children should look up to kyle
rittenhouse right like he's the he's the
uh the role model for them right if i
was
his mother i would be proud of kylo ren
house
and my takeaway outside of the fact of
like this is just terrible whether
you're stoking the fire or not i was
like
i was like regardless of your your
feelings about the verdict
young
children should not be arming themselves
and attending a protest like just like
any any parent who cares about their
children though i will say during the
pandemic
i've learned that parents have somehow
disabled the it like innate
uh
like caring ability to take to to to
protect their children or specifically
around covid so i'm like i don't know
maybe parents of this side do really
want to send their kids into the the war
zone but i saw that and i was like this
is the worst take i've seen today
outside of a
medley of others well when you're when
your uh ideology is basically just
anything anything and everything to own
the libs anything to to
to be anti-liberal when that's the
ideology is just like what we really are
is anti this thing like whatever these
people are for we're against it and they
want to say like it's the same on both
sides but like i've i've asked this
question several times throughout the
entire written house trial and no one's
been able to just answer the question
and it's because they can't answer the
question because
they can't answer the question in an
honest way but literally people won't
they won't even address it and i'll just
say just answer me this question what
would your position be if there was a
uh a trump rally that got a little out
of hand and a black teenager showed up
with an ar-15 and killed two trump
supporters what would your position be
would your position be he was there you
know trying to defend the property there
he was trying to help out and let's say
it was the ex let's say it was the exact
same situation like like beat for beat
exact same situation what would your
position be
and
knowing that they can't answer that
question honestly because it's like you
wouldn't you wouldn't have the same take
and i think they would turn around and
go ah you'd feel the same way if the you
know
you know
you you would back up the black teenager
in that situation i'm like no though i
wouldn't actually if i if you showed me
a footage of like say january 6 that
like let's say an antifa kid rolled up
you know with with like a
you know a blm like mask on and he
pulled out a gun and like shot two
two
insurrectionists in the back of the head
i'd be like yeah that kid's um that kid
needs to go to jail like yeah i think
that's that's just like the the
the broken sense of reality that they
have where they'll look at and be like
you know we talked about this a little
earlier um
which is like oh you guys are you guys
love you know hate trump love uh love
biden and they'll go into that like like
we
you know are like bowed down before him
and it's like no we call out we hold
accountable for anyone on our side that
does something
as opposed to your side which is like
you do it our way or you gotta go well
and and and their way is just
anti-liberal it's just anti-left it's
just right racism and it's like so
whatever it is to to be
against
woke culture or anything like that
whereas whereas on the left i love that
i love that oh oh yeah yeah woke wow
they they love their little they're i
mean you know what woke me you know what
woke means right
do you guys know what woke means to
white to to white people in middle
america who are trump supporters they
don't mean people here's what they mean
black people and people who like black
people that's what they mean i'm dead
serious i'm dead serious definitely
that's the code word that's the code
word it's dog whistles
and slogans and that's all it is whereas
you know again on the left it's like oh
democrats are
an infuriating uh political party like
they're constantly showing little to no
backbone on campaign promises and
unwilling to actually implement
progressive policies that would actually
fix problems they can on the campaign
trail they can talk all they they want
about canceling student loans and and uh
and they do actually talk about that
kind of [ __ ] they talk about that [ __ ]
all the time i've been hearing it for
years and then when it comes to actually
getting in office for whatever reason
they show no backbone and they they're
constantly about compromising with a
party that has shown over and over again
that has no interest in compromise right
and has you know so i i'm i have no
problem criticizing uh the democratic
apparatus and party and the political
power structure um but when it comes to
who i would rather be in the driver's
seat given that i have two options to me
it's like there's there's not even a
contest well yeah i mean obviously
someone who's got their license had
their license for a long time cares
about knowing about how to drive takes
continuing education classes on how to
drive or the person who has never driven
never seen a car in their entire life
and is drunk all at the same time and
who believes that like
rules are what you say they are right
exactly or or freedom yeah or or
believes at first glance that they would
be an expert uh like race driver like
car driver race driver
right well you know like it's their
privilege it's their privilege to be
right i mean i mean look at the pandemic
everyone became an expert in uh
everything and you're like
i didn't know that you could get a full
medical degree in three months when it
took you yeah right eight years right
i saw a good take today that said that
the reason why or one of the reasons why
these people are incapable of engaging
with
the conversation about races in america
in uh intellectually honest way is that
they know on some level whether it's
conscious or unconscious they know that
it's not based in logic or reason that
it's a it's an emotional position it's a
feeling they have a feeling they have a
a cultural like they were raised to just
feel a certain way about certain
communities and certain people and they
can't back it up with a logical argument
so they make the argument about anything
other than what it actually is because
they they fancy themselves as people who
are
rational logical people uh intellectuals
and you know they're they're the facts
over feelings crowd but actually all of
their positions are feelings based their
emotional feelings right they don't like
liberals they don't like like this woke
business they don't they don't like
certain communities because they've been
taught not to and it doesn't make any
rational sense in their head it's just a
feeling it's an emotional position
and since they can't
i mean that's you know yeah and that's
that's why uh like during you know from
2016 and through this last election the
reason that trump is so popular is
because he stoked the the emotion of
anger and frustration and hatred and he
would say when he came in he's like i'm
just a normal guy like you yeah i made
billions
uh but
um
i have
this point of view or perspective on
this thing and then you as a spectator
go yeah i also i agree with that that's
the same problems i have and then he
says another one you go yeah yeah and
then you begin to
map in your mind and you create a new
behavior that you're like well if he was
right about these two or three things
that i also agree with then he's right
about everything else also though going
to the to the perspective of that their
ideology is an ideology of
anti-liberalism they see what like they
saw i think they saw the way that the
left reacted to donald trump so
vitriolically and they loved
anything that pisses liberals right like
they're just like oh well then this is
our guy and the other thing the other
thing about trump was he was so ant he
was like the the anti-obama right like
he was he was he he was like there
their guy who hated obama no matter what
no matter what it was about obama he
could hate obama the way that they
wanted to hate obama because no other
politician really hated obama
like trump did yeah i mean that brother
everything that was you know everything
happened and also at the at the the
rallies that he would have he would
literally say out and there's also that
investigation that's happening right now
but one of the rallies where those
people were
attacked
and there's the whole thing of like
who's accountable when he says things
like get that son of a [ __ ] out right
right he's he's he's inciting it right
right he's like i'll cover the legal
fees which he did
of course not
he won't even he won't even pay rudy
giuliani for going around selling all
that [ __ ] election fraud [ __ ] he
doesn't cover his own legal fees yeah
right right
he's not gonna pay for yours you dumb
[ __ ]
so so i wanna i wanna i wanna tell you
guys two things because i wanna go back
to the question
that you had earlier austin about uh a
black kid showing up a 17 year old black
kid showing up at a at a maga rally with
a gun
or or a genuine first of all that kid
doesn't make it into police cuts to be
alive well that's exactly what i was
going to say i was going to say i i
don't even think that kid gets the
opportunity to fire that weapon
not even get
they'll kill him on site yeah um it is
it that was going to be my point uh to
your to answer and if i could answer if
i could answer as one of them like if i
can pretend to be one of them for a
second i'd say you know what when he
shows up with a gun not only not only is
the cops gonna shoot that son of a [ __ ]
but we're gonna we're gonna execute him
on that's what they would say oh yeah
that's what they would say and they
would probably throw a nice little
n-word in there too
with it any any opportunity
to be vitriolic about with their racism
but to couch it in something that
seems like reasonable or legal where
it's like oh well if he's if he's
assaulting me if he's showing up with a
with a firearm and threatening my safety
now i can call him an animal now i can
call it right a thug like any
opportunity wait a second you mean that
black kid
bought that weapon illegally crossed
state lines his mother drove him there
in a car oh my i mean they would use all
the things that you're like hey here's
the logical reason why kyle rittenhouse
wasn't there to be a medic and and you
would use all all the logical reasonable
things that you would use as evidence
they would use it as vitriol i think
back to uh what you guys were talking
about with the democrats and in
washington
and trump
guys i actually believe that the reason
why democrats lose the reason why the
left loses two reasons number one it's a
huge tent right so like there's all
these different parties quote unquote
there's the bernie supporters that which
are democratic socialists there's
moderates there's anti-trumpers there's
just independents who are like well i
vote democrat because republicans are
[ __ ] nuts right i mean there's all
these there's all these people inside
this quote-unquote party and i think the
problem is is that the party on the hill
has a met has a problem with messaging
and unfortunately in the political
climate that we are now the only way for
messaging to catch on in the masses and
to piss people off enough to go [ __ ]
vote and be engaged is vitriol and i you
know i don't want to say that the left
needs to keep with the vitro
but i'm also saying that if they if they
try to play to this only facts no
feelings
we're never we're never going to capture
enough votes for these fascists not to
take over and for this fascism to strive
in our country so i want i want i want
to be clear and
i know that there's probably different
feelings about this but
i i believe that in our political
climate now if we don't use some
divisive language because we have to be
intolerant of the intolerant and that is
not it that is not um a bad thing to be
intolerant of intolerance and i think
that's part of the problem with
democrats
and what i mean by democrats is big d
democrats not small d democrats in that
the left um again that big tent where
you have you have actual republicans in
the democratic party now who are
pro-life who who are who want lower
taxes but they're like i don't want to
be on the side of people going to dallas
texas to wait for jfk junior to show up
to run with donald trump like i don't
that's but not only that but it's it's
the fact of like i may have these uh
ideologies around basic human rights you
know access to free health care and
education or taxes or what have you
uh but there's just that fear that both
sides have become so polarized but
especially the right has become so
polarized where it's like either us or
them right there's no middle ground
right where that they may have these
um
these these feelings um of how things
should be right in terms of policies
that align with democrats however they
can't say it
because if they say it then they become
enemy of the state within the republican
party and everyone from donald trump to
whoever you know now says
this person
uh isn't with us
and then because of then they fear that
their constituents who are you know very
susceptible to messaging and narrative
and fox news and everything that then
they will say like well
they and then there's a long list of
that someone will make of some
misinformation to say
john doe who's running for this for
re-election is actually
not a republican and they believe blah
blah blah blah and all the like
terrible things that are said around you
know just
things that you should have as a as a
human right right the whole strategy now
is that everyone needs to imitate trump
as much as they possibly can if they
want to get elected which is just uh
you know it's just disgusting but it's
also like i think it is kind of the
optimistic view of it is that
all of those people who are like i'm not
doing that i'm not i'm not pretending to
be that guy and if that means that i no
longer can be a part of this party then
i guess i'll have to find a home
somewhere else but i see people like so
one of the things i see in my comments
all the time is
people who identify as a conservative or
someone on the right but they'll they'll
just let me know they'll be like i just
want to let you know that i don't agree
with you politically but i really like
your content and i'll be like what do
you mean they're just like i like your i
just think you're funny and i like your
music and i like the way that you like
you articulate your points but like i
don't always agree with them and then
i'll talk to these people be like so
like what what do you disagree with and
they'll be like well it should
they'll be like i'm a christian and i'm
from like this place right but
i do actually think that you're right
about a lot of the things that you
criticize about the modern right and i
just i don't know how to say that to my
family but and i'm like
the more i get them talking the more i'm
like i don't think you are what you
think you are right yeah you're so used
to identifying as this one thing but i
think that the party that you used to be
a part of has is gone and you've been
left to the bus it doesn't exist right
right yeah you're at you're at the
station and the train is left yeah like
trumpism took over and you you never
were really on board with it yeah but
you couldn't you've always voted
republican and
look
republicans have always i mean since the
80s and ronald reagan have been [ __ ]
over the economy with this idea of just
letting wealth inequality grow
exponentially and it will trickle down
somehow and that has been proven over
the last 40 years to be demonstrated
just over and over again to be false
it's a it's a wrong idea so republicans
have always had
some bad ideas but trumpism is a whole
new it's just a whole new branch i call
it i call it fascism in a manga hat is
what i yeah yeah it's just
authoritarianism setting the stage for
fascism for like
literally the end of american democracy
right right yeah well and that's what i
mean by big ten is i think like anyone
who's pro-democracy is anti-trumpism
[ __ ] yeah right they're like you know
like i i agree with some of the stuff
he's saying some of those policies but
at the same time i'm pro-democracy i'm
not i'm not gonna bow down
to to grandpa poopypants to the mango
mussolini jesus and pray to the altar of
the cheeto dust mobster i'm just not
going to do it so speaking speaking of
of crazy points of view
and austin responding to crazy points of
view i have another i think i may i i
don't know there's a lot of videos on um
yeah there's a lot
on australia but i may have i may have
one that was pinned to the top that's
got a lot of attention so let's play
that and then we'll talk about it
uh
[Music]
congratulations that was one of the
stupidest things that i've ever seen
anybody post on the internet before
congratulations
the bar is high cause people boast lots
and lots of stupid things but your
stupid thing was somehow the leader of
the pack
you just said i don't know what pronouns
are and i won't learn cause learning's
hard instead i'll regurgitate a half
fake stolen opinion
people like you make me sad
sad
sad
[Music]
yeah so is this like like when you're
when you're developing this content to
respond to like this person you were
responding to their tick tock video
obviously
do you like like do you watch the video
of this person and you're like this idea
comes to you are you like i have to
respond so then you make this content
and then you're like it has to be a song
or it has to be a sketch what what is
that process
tell us how the the your pal austin soup
is made we want to know the secret yeah
you know tick tock's kind of an idea
factory if you're scrolling through tick
tock long enough and you're a content
creator like you'll find something to
make a video about whether it's a trend
that you're jumping on or whether it's
like a video that like everyone the last
few weeks has been just dog piling on
that misfit patriot dude
what a [ __ ] dickwad you know but it
gave everyone content it just gave
everyone content and uh and i i made one
video and then i was like i honestly was
like i think it's enough with this guy
right i think part of me is like i think
he might like hurt himself and i'm kind
of like i don't want to like i you know
uh granted i'm not like i don't have a
lot of sympathy for the guy like he he
absolutely is reaping what he sowed but
uh he but it's you know so anyway if i
see a video like this uh i'll usually
think i could probably make a response
and then it's like the debate of like am
i going to do
a response where i just say one thing
like like a one-liner response where
it's just like a quippy remark am i
gonna do a video where it's gonna be
like an academic analysis of their take
and i'm going to be like uh get the katy
board white katy porter whiteboard out
or something i do those too or it's like
let's break this down
let's talk about but it take like that
and a lot of people pointed out in the
comments they're like he was joking he
was trolling oh my god and i'm like kate
i don't really care what it is because i
thought that video got 23 million views
thousands of people came into my
comments saying yeah i wouldn't date a
girl with pronouns either like smh like
what the [ __ ] like i don't want to date
pronoun people either and i'm like the
fact that so many of you genuinely don't
know what pronouns are which it goes it
goes right back to the fake outrage
right you don't know what you're yelling
about but you're yelling for the sake of
yelling because everyone else around you
that is like you is yelling about
something because this is yeah this is
the other comment that i would get is
people would go you know what he meant
like you know what he was trying to say
and i'm like i do know what he meant i
do know that the
is people with pronouns in their bio or
people who use alternative pronouns like
they them or uh z z or z
like i i know what the the person is
saying what i'm saying is the fact that
they don't know
what the [ __ ] a pronoun is and that they
think that pronouns are just anything
that is like
any alternative thing or someone who
puts something in their bio that they
don't understand that they have pronouns
that like
i'm that everyone has pronouns uh is
what i'm talking about that people are
lacking a basic level of understanding
of this like on a basic fundamental
level the thing that they're mad about
they don't understand but i've also i've
also had a similar situation where you
know i'll make characters that are
obviously uh you know an exaggeration
but are based on real things that are
said in my comments there's real things
that are said yeah out online and i'm
like here's this character i made based
on what was said
and then much like the people that are
going in and you know and going in
against pronouns because they don't
understand what they are
uh on my videos you know i'll have
trumpers or whoever that will that will
just continue the sketch in the comments
yes yes and then you're like you are
validating this person that i created
they like and then they're like
that's not real
these people don't exist no one's ever
said that they can't [ __ ] help it
like they can't help but run to the
comments to validate the video right
they can't and they'll and they'll jump
into the comments and be like nice straw
man dude and then do the thing
do the thing that you're like you're
doing the thing
but but to answer the question about the
process that video in particular uh if
there's going to be a song written i
need to have an idea that pops to mind
because the songs take more time they
take more planning that's what wait wait
you mean you just don't just pop these
out and boom
i i i am sorely disappointed that it
takes you more than five minutes to come
up with these songs
i did a rap the other day i posted a
video of me rapping and someone in the
comments was like you wrote that rap
down before you filmed it and i was like
yeah
yeah
you totally should have said nope nope
totally freestyle
off the top well not harry mack do you
guys know harry mack like he's a
freestyler on tick-tock who like he's
he's incredible he's absolutely amazing
um but i'm like yeah i'm not i didn't
say i was freestyling i didn't say right
that's the top of my dome because then
in that video you were like i saw the
mom do it so i thought it was fired yeah
i saw him so there's landing that goes
with it but like but
that that song in particular the thing
that's crazy about that song and this is
talking about the algorithm and we
talked about this a little bit earlier
that like we can't plan which videos are
gonna pop off and which videos are gonna
get stuck that video uh
i've worked so much harder on other
videos than that one that one i saw that
video and literally that first line just
popped into my head and it fits so
nicely the congratulations that was one
of the stupidest things that i've ever
seen like it all like rhymed nicely and
fit the meter nicely that i sat down
wrote the song on my computer in like
maybe 20 minutes and then i shot the
video that night and it took me like 15
minutes to shoot another 20 minutes to
edit one of the easiest videos i've ever
put together and it's by far the most
viral video i've ever made and it was
like
so easy so quick and dirty and i didn't
expect it to do very well at all and i
woke up the next day and i was like oh
my god this one's like huge yeah that
one that one got you from it was like a
couple hundred thousand to over or close
to eight hundred right i gained four
hundred thousand followers from that
video
holy [ __ ] yeah so it is so so that so
i'll tell you that i i think you're
right that like you know when you are
making this content you don't know what
the algorithm because i think there's
two sides of the algorithm to be honest
with you there's the side where
the algorithm is saying okay this is the
input but also it's got an output and
what i mean by that is like on tick tock
i've noticed a lot of my videos that the
algorithm likes like it'll push those
videos right and then the videos that it
doesn't like it doesn't so it forces me
it forces me to make the videos you know
quote unquote the videos that it wants i
noticed i do my [ __ ] walking rants
which i haven't done one in a while but
i used to do those
and i noticed that
it was like the outside light and the
sky behind me and i know that sounds
crazy that the algorithm's like oh
there's sky behind him but i really do
think that is what the algorithm wanted
from my videos and my account because
tick tock's like and i think you
actually made a video about this austin
like you're gonna give us what we want
you to give us and you're not gonna
[ __ ] about it and then when you don't
give us the stuff that that we don't
want to give to the algorithm we're
gonna tell you to go [ __ ] yourself and
we're gonna give you 15 views and you're
going to go back to making the [ __ ] that
we want oh yeah tony have you ever tried
to make a video advertising your podcast
i i try to post clips in my podcast all
the time they're like [ __ ] you
a couple hundred views that's all you
can try to do anything that's
advertising outside stuff that's like
hey i have an album out or i have like i
i'm i'm on cameo
they're just like [ __ ] you absolutely
not like you're not going to push
traffic away from our site to whatever
[ __ ] you're trying to get people
right right it's like
like it has nothing to do with whether
or not the audience doesn't like it
because when i make those videos they'll
get like 8 000 views but like have 2500
likes so i'm like right it's not like
people aren't
engaging with this content it's just
that the platform is going no nope [ __ ]
you not gonna do it well it's like it's
it's like that uh you know
when you're you know you're an artist
and you're creating something and people
know you for that thing and you're like
great that was one phase of my artist
journey right second phase and people
like no [ __ ] that go back go back and
you're like well i'm trying something
new i'm experimenting and they're like
no no no no no no i want the old [ __ ]
all right [ __ ] and so audiences
traditionally have done that like you
hear this a lot in music where like a
band will try a new thing and people
will be like i don't like it i don't
like that they you know that they're
expanding their horizons but like
we live in the age where the algorithm
decides for us like i find that my
audience is generally down for me trying
different things and they're down for
like when people hear about it at least
at least 20 or 30 times a week i have
people who in my comments will say hey
you should start a podcast and i'll be
like i have a podcast i try to tell
people about it all the time and so i
have to tell like one person at a time
but they're always like oh my god like
how come i don't know about this like
they're down for the different things
it's just that the algorithm has decided
we want you making the songs or like
funny skits and that's
get off your ass and write some songs
would you please so so that's a good
point back to
the podcast thing and all that because
here's what i found i went over to
twitter
and when i went over to twitter i found
like i i could actually
uh
use the word curate but i could curate
my content that i wanted how how i
wanted to do it right it gave me more
freedom as in i wasn't just posting a
video and seeing what the algorithm does
right so i can go over there and i can
work hard to get it going um instagram's
a totally different animal the podcast
algorithm a totally different animal
like they want different things right so
like that's the thing about content
creators and a lot of people are a lot
especially when a content creator breaks
on all diff different social media
platforms it's like if you can do that
as a content creator it's huge and the
reason why is because the algorithms are
looking for different things for those
pieces of content and i think a lot of
people you know all three of us are
content creators and so we're kind of
like patting each other on the back
right but but i mean but i mean at the
same time you know some people
maybe do or don't understand like the
content that we're creating
sometimes isn't for an audience it's for
the algorithm to gain an audience and
then once you gain the audience
do you keep doing that same stuff that
you got or do you change like gabe's
saying and do you do different things
because i get requests all the time like
oh you should do this topic you should
do one of your walking rants and i'm
like yeah well i'm so busy doing this
other stuff this other content that i
don't have time to go do that piece of
content even though you want it and so
it's a challenge like
what algorithm do you play to what
audience do you play to because they're
all different audiences too have you
found that like each one of your social
media platforms yeah is a different
audience and they want different things
from your content yeah
definitely uh and it it's weird like
that there are different people who
follow me on twitter than there are who
follow me on instagram and like and like
the people who follow me on instagram
don't follow me on tik tok and the
people who follow me on twitter don't
follow me anywhere but twitter and it's
like that's and i know because when i
post stuff they're like that's when
they're getting it right on twitter
um but i i view it as like i don't
i don't really worry about the fact that
i just know certain videos aren't gonna
do well but i make them anyway because i
like making them right sort of like a
like when a like a filmmaker talks about
like like one for them one for me like
where they're like i'll make one for the
studios so that i can gain some trust
with like the studio execs and like get
them to like give me money on my next
one but the next one's mine like the
next one right i get to do what i want
to do right next one's my small movie
that no one's gonna go see but like a
handful of people are gonna see it and
they're really gonna like it and they're
gonna reach out to me and be like that's
the movie that's the movie right there
and that's i make those i make these
like more personal videos that like
don't do as well but like the people
that see them are like that's the [ __ ]
you know and i'm like yeah right
so so so here's the thing or you could
do like this special you know
independent thing or you could go like
the kevin costner when he did dances
with wolves right he like gained the
trust already just everyone's like this
dancing little thing is not gonna work
it's not gonna work and he doesn't he
goes big now speaking of going big and
collaborating on content and doing what
you want and then trying to collaborate
on another piece of content i one of my
all-time favorite your pal austin videos
is turtlenecks and blazers and of course
i have i'm gonna play here
the the original version but there's a
couple different versions so let's
listen to it and then let's talk about
the collaboration and how those videos
came to be on the other side what do you
want to wear tonight i don't know what
do you want to wear tonight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
got something for you
whether you're a college professor
or a business woman in the 80s
[Music]
that that is i think that has to be
uh one of my all-time favorites um
and how i originally seen it was
uh it's kevin chamberlain right yeah
because he was on he's on a show my
daughter watches uh jesse he's on uh he
plays uh the butler i forget the
character's name but he plays the butler
on the disney show
i i know kevin because he's an old
broadway star like kevin's done a lot of
broadway things and i'm like a broadway
guy i'm like a musical theater guy and
so when kevin first did the video i was
like dude that's kevin chamberlain and
so yeah it was a big deal for me to have
kevin chamberlain do the video that's
really cool well it was really cool
because like like they took this great
song that you had and they took the
sound
and like did this vid and i wish i had
it here to play but i don't but did that
they had this go search for it out there
on the interwebs
i'm sure it's there it's better than the
original it's better you mean like the
video not that because the sound is
exactly the same yeah but like but their
video is like it takes it up oh oh it
was like the the the art that they put
on like the the the 1980s you know like
like it just it the whole video is
fantastic so that's when i first seen it
and i already
like i already followed you on tick tock
and then i'm like what wait a second
this is so i went once the original but
tell us a story about this video
where you got like your video did well
the kevin chamberlain video did like
extremely well but then you try to
create another piece of content and the
audience is like nah no not gonna or the
algorithm which is it which is it i
think it was a mixture of both on this
one um but it
yeah like this just goes to show that
like none of us know what the [ __ ] we're
[Laughter]
we doing like we don't know why stuff is
popular when it is right and why it
isn't when it isn't and you know it's
easy to chalk it up to just like the
algorithm and i think a lot of it is
that
but also like
i don't know like if enough people had
shared this video maybe it would have
done better but
so
kevin chamberlain and these guys do this
video
i'm so blown away i'm so starstruck and
like i you know i've been listening to
kevin chamberlain on cast recording
since i was a teenager and i reached out
to them and i said hey uh you know like
we should
we should do a do something together you
know and right and they were like
totally down and he's got a guy that
directs all of his videos like so he's
got like a team he's got like a
production team that makes the content
with him
and they so they we started having like
production meetings over zoom we had
like three different production meetings
about this video
about the one song about the one video
wow
and so i wrote this whole song it was
called um mustache respect and it was
about
uh being guys with mustaches and seeing
each other in public and like respecting
each other for our mustaches and like
connecting over our mustaches and we
just thought like this thing's gonna be
huge and we we shot the thing over three
days at four different locations this is
this is a 60-second song right 60-second
song
we shot on a yacht we shot on a lot of
a little dinghy we shot at a dive bar
and we shot at a um a barber shop and we
had all these different setups and it
was like a whole production and we like
we were just like well this thing's
going to be huge this thing's going to
break the internet this thing's going to
be right right as their video went huge
they're just turning like a blazer video
was all over the internet it was
everywhere and uh we just thought like
okay so the turtleneck blazer like guys
that
and the guy who wrote the song are come
coming together to do a song about
mustaches and we're like this is gonna
be huge there's no way this is going to
fail no way
too big to fail
it's such a usable sound it's like
anyone who has a mustache can use this
sound for themselves like that's kind of
what you're looking for on tick tock too
is like like the congratulations song
it's like this is a sound that people
can repurpose for so many different
things like congratulations that was one
of the most stupid things i've ever seen
i would say on the internet like
everyone can can grab that and go oh i'm
going to use this for this comment or
you know we thought that's how this was
going to be and it just tanked it just
like it did so poorly
and we were all so like dumbfounded by
it and just like what did we do wrong
where did we misstep and that's when we
really realized like we have no control
over this right right well and and it
could be there they were like um
mustaches no it's turtlenecks and
blazers okay
okay like who knows and and you're right
like who knows
what it could be because i think you can
you know on certain social media
platforms like stoke
you know the the the
it going viral
you know by by getting certain people to
share it and getting people to do with
it or whatever whatever each platform
has
but at the same time you're not going to
control what the audience does when they
push those buttons and they go to
comment well speaking about uh also like
out what the algorithm likes and what it
doesn't like i for whatever reason and i
can't really pinpoint why this is
traditionally have done really
poorly with collaborations no matter who
i'm collaborating with and i've
collaborated oh well that's great
okay cut the interview off we're done
that's enough i'm out of here
it's so i have a friend who has uh six
and a half million followers on tick
tock and he and i do videos together
right pretty frequently but every time
we do a video together at tanks and i'm
always like apologizing to him i'm
always like sorry man i don't know what
and he's like dude
like he doesn't give a [ __ ] he's got six
and a half million followers and he's
just like he's like it's fine but like
it's so weird that like our videos don't
do better together and any time i
collaborate with people it doesn't do
well and i have this theory that the
that the algorithm
yep just what i said earlier yeah
it like doesn't like when it can tell
that you're trying to like manufacture a
hit when it's like no we know what
you're trying to do here you're like
you're trying to like gain the system
and we we want this to be organic we
want look look here you son of a [ __ ]
you you go back to making the viral
content that you were making before we
don't like this stuff
we want it to be much better or we don't
want we don't want you to contrive it
yeah the uh well the the relationship
that the worst feeling is like for for
my videos i'll do green screens so you
know i will have to kind of create the
set whether it's like oh here's a prop
or there's some sort of backdrop or
whatever
and i'll be like uh
i'm like oh this is
this is gonna be good like yep you know
i'll put the effort in i like you know
i'm putting like little easter eggs here
and there writing the jokes or whatever
and some of them do really well and then
the other ones like i did one about uh
the other day that was about laura
ingram and the whole like you measles
mix-up comment that they were like
unscripted scripted
and i was like it's pretty good you know
like did well on twitter
and then on tick tock it was like uh
here's like a few thousand views you
know and i'm like
damn it
and it's just like it
for whatever reason you know it just
says uh that's a hit not a hit that's
going to do moderately okay that's just
going to tank you might as well delete
it because that's just embarrassing and
you're like this machine is is now
really hurting my
ego you and you really know
you get after a while you really know
that it is algorithmically based because
even trying to track the rhyme and
reason of like the patterns where like
you know if you get a video that in its
first hour being up has like 20 000
views you're like cool this one's gonna
this one's gonna rock like it's first
hour it it it took off which means
it's only going up from here uh and
sometimes that is the case like
sometimes it may like that is the case
but sometimes it'll be like 20 000 views
in the first hour and then by the end of
the day it has like 30 000 views and
you're like hold up so in hour one right
like
and then the rest of the day it just was
like
it's like it's like they're teasing you
yeah it's like they're teasing you
they're like hey this is going to be
really well our just kidding like
statistically this is not how it should
play out right if 20 000 people like
this this small like then if you travel
it out to a larger sample size like you
would then begin to see a similar
pattern however if you're gonna start uh
tapering me off
hours later with an extra 10
someone's finger is on the izama key you
know hey
maybe it's brad at tech support it's
brad in texas
yeah you stopped letting this through
you stopped letting this uh
be seen because that's really what it is
it's too good we're going to throttle
this man you know it's not like a it's
not like a tv show where like your tv
show is on at on thursday night at 7 p.m
and let's see how many people tune in
you know back in the 90s and early 2000s
it's like my tv show is live on the
internet but whether or not it shows up
on people's phone or computer is is just
it's just a it's a casino it's just
literally like it might show up or it
might not and
i never thought of it that way
what i never thought of it that way can
you imagine like in the 90s if instead
of like a tv schedule is just an
algorithm feeding you the tv that you
wanted to watch like that's that i never
even thought of it that that is a
perfect perfect way to look at it you
wanted you could go like seek out the
show that you want to watch right right
a lot easier
i guess seinfeld's on like i guess right
you know what's crazy is about the
netflix algorithm like the net netflix
algorithm will feed me videos and my
wife's like you're not really gonna
watch it i'm like well netflix wants me
to watch it
i'm like
netflix wants me to re-watch seinfeld
all nine seasons i mean so i'm gonna do
it that's exclusively how i watch
youtube i watch a lot of youtube and i
just want i go to i go to my home page
of youtube and i look at the whatever
eight videos are there on the home page
and you just start there huh and if i
don't like any of those i'll refresh
i'll just refresh like
give me a name it's like like a like a
goddamn slot machine right
i'll watch this seth meyers clip okay
yeah and then i'm like watching the seth
meyer's clip and then i go back to the
homepage i'm like
yeah okay i'll watch this watch mojo
list like all right you know like but
it's like i it knows generally what i
like to watch and it just is like john
oliver you want to watch this john
oliver clip and i'm like
not right now i'll watch that later uh
like but it's like
well you know you know what's crazy is
when i go to my own page on youtube it
shows me bluegrass music and that only
tells you like the difference between
what i'm watching on our list because i
listen to it more than anything uh while
i'm working is i mean it's pretty
impressive you now have programmed your
youtube algorithm to just give you blues
deadpool flat reds amazing that's very
impressive right it well it feeds me up
like old old old golden old uh country
bluegrass uh new new bluegrass which is
billy strings it's it's fantastic what
it feeds me and i love that algorithm
because it and a lot of times it feeds
me the exact same songs that i've
listened to 100 times so i like the
whole the whole feed so uh
before we before we forget because we
are we're going to have an extended
interview here i think uh gabe where
we're gonna be able to post an extended
interview uh past the show but we want
to play a trivia game oh i'm stoked
so let's let's play trivia real quick
all right well with uh thanksgiving
around the corner uh i figured we'd play
a little trivia game that's thanksgiving
based
so the rules are i'm going to ask you
uh five questions
and the first one to ring in on their
buzzer will get a chance to answer the
question if you get it wrong then your
opponent will have a shot for the point
and whoever answers the most points
after five questions
wins
are you two ready
buzzer's ready i i am ready i'm ready to
play
okay i'm ready to click my buzzer
question number one
when was the first and i'm gonna read
off options for these when was the first
thanksgiving nfl game a
1918
b
1920 or c
1926
i'm just gonna guess see
wrong it is not that all right tony you
have an opportunity here too do you need
me to read them out again
it's the first nfl game
on thanksgiving right
nfl national football league yes
on thanksgiving yes i'm gonna go with b
that is correct 1920.
question number two
who is the first president to pardon a
turkey a john f kennedy b richard nixon
c lyndon b johnson
i'm gonna go
with tricky dicky nixon wrong then i'm
gonna go
jfk ding ding ding you are correct
all right
one and one the score is one to one
i love how we work the nfl and politics
into the thanksgiving
uh trivia here yeah so far yeah
let's see what the rest have in store
all right question number three
what turkeys actually gobble a male b
female c both
is it not both no
okay all right
wait wait did he answer that question
no my my question was my answer was both
yeah oh okay okay okay i just i just
want to make sure that we're not like
we're not like giving a point i mean
there's a huge prize at the end here
austin that would be pretty cheap if i
was like can i
can i
can i ask you a question
dave if this is the correct answer i
took i want gabe to buzz in on my
question about the question you just
asked
it is mail correct two to one all right
here we go yes i'm just glad i'm just
glad i learned something new yeah only
male turkeys gobble yeah well did you
know that male turkeys can have more
than one beard and female turkeys can
also have beards i'm just throwing this
i don't didn't even know they had beards
turkeys have beards i'm
i'm from the country man where
we had we hang up
turkey beards on the wall because we're
proud of them
turkey okay
yeah wow that's i didn't know like
that's that's like a thing like how long
was its beard is that the thing the red
thing that hangs down no nope nope
that's no there is it has a it has a
tusk of hair it's like a it's like a
tassel almost but it is a beard okay
well now i just imagine turkeys with
full on beards no no no not like a beard
beard it's a it's like a like a beard
like a mirrored like a neck beard yeah
yeah right yeah sort of sure though all
right turkeys the original neck beards
[ __ ] old neck beard old turkey neck
beard yeah
question four about how many pumpkin
pies are consumed every thanksgiving a
40 million b 50 million c 60 million or
d 70 million
i want to go
70 million
correct that is right that is correct
yeah 70 million
i guess i figured the big the highest
one has to be it because yeah well i
mean i mean how many pumpkin pies like
like when you go to your thanksgiving
with your family like when you go like
you're like oh yeah i'm sure i'm sure
aunt sally will bring a pumpkin pie and
aunt sally's thinking well i better
bring one because no one else will bring
one and then and then aunt nancy's like
well i need to bring one too in case no
one remembers the pumpkin pie right so
like when you get there there's like
there's like a turkey and all the
fixings and then there's 35 pumpkin pies
right like
everyone has to eat their own pumpkin
pie do you guys have that experience at
thanksgiving
no
absolutely not okay well everyone eats
their own pumpkin pie no i'm saying i'm
saying when you show up so many people
everyone's like i want to make sure to
bring a pumpkin pie in case everyone
else forgets so everyone brings one so
there's like 35 pumpkin pumpkin pie
dough you've got a pecan pie apple pie
cherry pie what kind of [ __ ] monster
are you
well that is true but who doesn't eat a
slice of pumpkin pie like yeah you eat a
slice of pumpkin pie but what i'm saying
is people don't only bring pumpkin pie
to the party you know well but you have
to have pumpkin pie so all the ants
bring their own in case the other ants
forget the pumpkin pie
then you have like seven pumpkin pies
well yeah one and everyone has you have
to try to eat all the food right i mean
it is the midwest like
and they're all emerging from the same
safe way you know
well actually some ants some ants like
will purchase
the safeway one and put it in their own
little pan and make try to make everyone
think they [ __ ] made it like come on
we know that
no one wants you to make that at home
like you don't want someone to show up
oh
no absolutely not i have an aunt that
makes the greatest like like you're like
oh man like her pumpkin pie is the first
one to go and everyone's like i'm
getting in [ __ ] line of the pies
because they know if they don't get her
slice and she'll make like two or three
of them so there's like there's like two
or three of the really good homemade
pumpkin pies and then you're just left
with [ __ ] pies and then you're just well
i mean you know they're like the grocery
store pumpkin pies right they're they're
all sitting there and they eventually
get eaten because it's [ __ ] pumpkin
pie but you know you want you want that
the homemade
and then there's some of the desserts
that sit there no matter what that just
because they're not pumpkin pie they're
not pecan pie they're not you know
they're not any of these so i do have a
bonus question okay on the
pie
okay so
do americans prefer
pumpkin pie or apple pie i mean are you
asking about thanksgiving first of all
let me ask it's a
thing
this question is rigged if the question
is which do americans prefer just in
general which pie is more popular i'm
gonna say apple correct apple
yeah okay there's always there's always
an apple pie at thanksgiving too yeah
and and and probably that day it gets
ignored because there are so many other
pies in the mix here the rest of the
year you're eating apple pie right here
right oh
fourth of july you have to have apple
pie you know it's like the merc gotta
have the apple pie right the apple pie
and the flag and
all that kind of stuff yeah and so i get
it but it gets ignored on thanksgiving
we have a fifth question if we need a
sixth one we can bring it up according
to the guinness book of world records
how much does the heaviest turkey on
record weigh a 65 pounds b 72 pounds c
86 pounds d 93 pounds
i'm gonna go with
c86 oh
correct i will bring up a tiebreaker
question here we go how long
was the first thanksgiving celebration a
two days
b three days
c
four days
d five days the answer is e it was
actually a myth and it didn't really
happen and
the uh the indigenous people actually
like weren't there to like make friends
they heard them firing off guns and they
came to be like hey stop firing your
guns
you with your c you with your crt
you ate your crt
austin you crt the whole goddamn trivia
game
well technically i'm sure that is
correct uh i do need an answer from a b
c or d and i can read them off again if
you need to
read them off again okay a
two days
uh b three days c four days or d five
days let's go with five let's say they
just raged for five days
that's definitely what those white
people did uh incorrect i'm sorry um i'm
gonna say if you get this wrong no i'm
gonna say three days i'm gonna say three
days three days that is correct
yeah
final score
four to three you guys had everyone on
the edge of their seats i just want to
say this was a pleasure to conduct and
congratulations tony you are
the winner of trivia thanksgiving
edition
[Music]
all right
that was fun the one thing i want you to
do before we leave
is to
uh pimp yourself out to our audience not
just the cat not just the cam girl
cameos but tell us where we can find you
on the social medias and the interwebs
your pal underscore austin on tick tock
twitter and instagram
um or if you just look up austin archer
it'll probably pull up
you can find my music on apple music or
spotify if you look up austin archer
austin archer.com is my website my
podcast is called people pleaser with
austin archer austin archer on youtube
that's all of it good and welcoming the
same on cameo yeah on cameo oh yeah well
you know
go buy a christmas cameo gift don't
request like pictures of his feet or
anything yeah um
i really will do it that's real
but i will do it tammy okay good you're
good at the end of the day money talks
okay that's right that's right that's
right so and and sometimes money walks
or makes you take your shoes off i don't
know and walk carefully i
if you want to see my feet bad enough
like give me a give me a price that i
can work with and like i'll show you my
feet
[Laughter]
like like so are we talking like just
like a quick glimpse are we talking like
you put it in anything and you know mush
your your toes around different tiers
for different requests okay okay i see
so so so it
it the the more involved the higher the
price is going to be the freakier we're
getting the more
yeah
why i love i love that there may be some
salacious
austin archer uh content out there now
so i'm just happy we live in a world
that doesn't kink shame so if this ever
never like thought out into public that
like i had done these like foot videos
i'd be like are you shaming me right
like sex work for like getting paid
right right
sex work is work i truly believe that
i'm not joking i actually believe that's
right and and i'll tell you i'll tell
you i don't know if you pimped your only
fans but maybe maybe you should consider
is that what because tell us before we
go since we're on a podcast tell us
about what yours is yeah my podcast is
uh it's called people pleaser with
austin archer and it's a different guest
every week and we just we just i talk
about a different thing every week you
know it's it's not a it's not a new idea
it's just a discussion show it's uh
like i i had wanted to start a podcast
for years and then i started one two
years ago and i just decided because
every time i i thought of like a single
idea to to build a podcast around i was
like i'm going to run out of episodes
like run out of content in 10 episodes
and be like well that's all of it we've
said everything i want to say
about that you just do i mean you could
just do like category like limited run
here's a podcast here's a podcast here's
a podcast and be like i had 20 podcasts
well that's i mean but that's kind of
what my show is is it's like this week
we're talking about this this week we're
like and it's always different like
sometimes it's really lighthearted and
easy and sometimes it's funny i mean i
did did an episode with a guy where we
just talked about the fast and the
furious movies because i love talking
about those movies and like and i do
episodes like that i talk to stand-up
comedians about comedy i talk to writers
about writing musicians about music i
talk to but then i also talk to people
about like you know we're talking about
like
the police and about racism in america
and about uh the january sixth
insurrection and i talked to neurosci
scientists about brains and like how
brains work and stuff and so
uh it's just like it's just a different
topic every week and we just sort of
zero in on that thing and and focus on
that thing so you have like a jar
somewhere in your house that you have
all these things written on slips of
paper and you're just like reaching in
you're like oh we're gonna talk about
brains this week and then that's
when i first start so the the podcast is
it'll be two years old in uh in in a
week and it'll happen i'm having my
100th episode in two weeks which is
really exciting congratulations that's
awesome
when i first started out it was like any
time i met someone that that specialized
in a certain field i would just be like
oh you should come on my podcast and
talk about that and now that my internet
presence has grown significantly i just
encounter these people all the time and
i'll just like encounter a person that
just like has a specialty in a certain
area and i'll be like oh you should we
should talk about that on my show and it
just makes it a lot easier to be like
this person is you know like i
like is a therapist that specializes in
trauma so let's talk about trauma with
this person they have a book coming out
so it's good timing to have them on the
show talk about their book and we'll
talk about trauma and like and so i just
i find a lot of these people just on the
internet and based on what their kind of
thing is or or even if it's not
necessarily their whole thing but i
think it'd be something that they would
know a lot about i'll just be like hey
do you want to come on and talk about
this yeah so i so i see myself as kind
of a strange person right so like i want
to have other strange weird people on
the podcast so we're really trying to
book
weird strange people
on i mean i'm not saying
no i i really appreciate you coming on
it's it's a pleasure having you and come
back any time really anytime you have
something you want to talk about when
you when you want a free space the one
thing i do have to ask before we leave
because everyone knows me for the for
the phrase [ __ ] them we have to get you
to say [ __ ] them at least three or four
different times here like the kyle
written house defense attorneys [ __ ] um
there you go written house prosecution
[ __ ] um those guys [ __ ] it up uh that
judge [ __ ] em and uh everyone that is
calling itself defense and is
celebrating this uh verdict [ __ ] them
matt gates for saying that he's gonna
hire him as an intern [ __ ] him tucker
carlson for having him on his show to
talk about how he's a big hero now [ __ ]
him and everyone at fox news [ __ ] up
[ __ ] [ __ ] em [ __ ] em
[Music]
find us on twitter at tony michael's pod
and at the tony michaels or be lame and
don't [ __ ] boneheads
we'll be back in 60 seconds
[Music]
[ __ ] spread nick
and that's why that's why he's getting
his shows canceled ain't because travis
tritt wants to cancel him
think about this think about the phone
call
travis calls up to the venue then he's
like hey travis we can't let anyone in
that's not vaccinating and he's like
what do you mean well he can't let
anyone in that's not vaccinated he says
well me and my entire band aren't
vaccinated they're like
you can't come in our building
well how the hell is travis tripp gonna
do a [ __ ] country music show if him
and his entire [ __ ] band can't enter
the [ __ ] building think about it
travis tritt isn't canceling shows
he's getting cancelled by the [ __ ]
venues who are like nah
no no one can come in you can't come in
without a vaccine passport you or anyone
else dumb [ __ ]
that travis tritt isn't canceling shows
he's getting his shows canceled because
he's a [ __ ] bonehead
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess
well now there's boycott binder the
ingenious organizer that keeps track of
everything and everyone you've ever
boycotted the 72 category filing system
makes it easy to organize boycotted
people places and things so you can find
them with ease the large centered area
can even fit your boycott sign but best
of all when you're done the boycott
binder folds right up so you can take it
anywhere so if you're tired of having a
cluttered mess call now and get the
boycott binder for just 29.99
plus you'll also receive our next rep as
a bonus just loop it around your neck to
travel with ease but call right now and
we'll double the offer that's two
boycott binders and two neck straps for
just 29.99
boycott binders brought to you by the
same makers of binders full of women
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast that was a great
great interview
had a lot of fun
playing
thanksgiving
trivia
with our uh our scorekeeper gabe
and
and the great austin archer your pal
austin had a lot of fun with that one
had a lot of fun
you know uh uh gabe i don't know if you
uh if you have any extra comments on the
interview there but
uh
i learned a lot about uh well
specifically
the turkey nerds yeah the the neck
beards yeah the neckties
you know i had no idea when i was when i
was i had to google it later
to really know that you were telling the
truth
well well what that i only
only tell the truth i don't know
you fact-checked me as well yeah i i had
to fact-check you i went to
you know duckduckgo
and
perfect perfect place to fact-check yeah
the turkeys have neckbeards or not and
it's really weird they're so weird they
just like hang off yeah yeah so so
that's like the thing like like oh i
shot a turkey this weekend you know
during turkey season like oh how much
did it weigh and then how long was the
beard like that's because the older they
get the longer the i mean that's kind of
the ideas the older they are the and the
bigger they are the bigger the beard
right so you're supposed to only shoot
the older ones yeah i well the old ones
well because you want you want good
stock so meaning like you don't you want
to shoot the younger ones because
they're the ones that are going to make
more turkey or you know help the females
make more turkeys you know i i i would
have known there is turkey sex gabe and
sex work
is work like we were saying i don't
think that talk is appropriate for any
of those
speaking of our listeners i want to say
uh we do have uh bonehead of the week
going this week even though it's
thanksgiving uh here's your contestants
on bonehead of the week we have kyle
rittenhouse uh tucker carlson and alex
jones for the bone now the week so go
over to our podcast account uh at tony
michael's pod and go go vote for the
bone end of the week and we'll do a
little video like we did last week
everyone really liked that bone end of
the week um so we're gonna we're gonna
continue to do the bone end of the week
watch for those every week
vote for who you want to be the bone end
of the week and we'll do a video and i
want to say to everyone happy
thanksgiving uh have a safe and very
nice thanksgiving finally you get to get
together with your vaccinated family i
hope you guys have a good thanksgiving
gabe and uh
yeah as well let's let's uh let's have
some let's kick off the holidays the
right way us vaccinated folks the
unvaccinated go [ __ ] themselves
vaccinated and full of gluttony that's
right [ __ ] up [ __ ] up we'll see you next
week uh wednesday three o'clock central
four o'clock eastern youtube twitter
twitch don't don't forget to go download
the uh episodes on all your favorite
directories spotify
apple google all those things and until
next week [ __ ] em
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking